bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france joe biden déclaré vainqueur quel
est le sens aujourd'hui de cette visite
diplomatique de mike pompéo est-ce que
c'est là une tournée d'adieux ou alors
une façon au contraire de dire que la
ministre à ce que l'administration trup
elle tient toujours les rênes de la
maison blanche
écoutez votre reportage la parfaite pour
ont montré il est et reste jusqu'au 20
janvier après midi le secrétaire d'état
et non sans malice il a rappelé son
souhait de ne pas reconnaître la
victoire de joe biden est au contraire
de s'inscrire dans une prolongation
d'une deuxième administration de troc le
bilan - on l'a quand même l'impression
qu'une dizaine de jours enfin pardon une
semaine deux déplacements à l'étranger
avec des visites très symbolique ils
valent se rendre après la france en
turquie alors il ne rencontrera pas le
président erdogan mais rencontrera le
patriarche de l'église orthodoxe
bartholomée et il aura évidemment aussi
les rencontres tout à fait symbolique
est né au moins importante démontrant
qu'il ya une forme de hiatus qui peut
exister entre cette administration
américaine est peut être la prochaine
sur un certains dossiers notamment à la
vis-à-vis l'état d'israël ou des états
du golfe où il va se rendre
donc d'une certaine façon ça peut donner
l'impression que c'est un baroud
d'honneur mais ça s'inscrit dans là deux
formules sont en train d'être très
traditionnel diplomatique ou pour les
deux prochains mois encore il sans doute
après le temps que l'administration
maiden se mettre en place
il y aura une à temps de latence au
cours duquel évidemment les américains
ne valent pas totalement déserté le
champ diplomatique
alors à quoi vont ressembler ces
prochains mois en termes de diplomatie
américaine d'ici à l'investiture du
nouveau président entre donald trump
dans le côté joe biden de l'autre est ce
qu'il n'ya pas risque finalement
d'engollon diplomatique jusqu'au 20
janvier
non parce que les institutions
américaines sont bien faites et le 20
janvier dans l'après midi il y aura un
nouveau secrétaire d'état peut-être
est-ce que ce sera mike pomper ou
manche un autre issue donc de l'issue
donc de ce vote qui semble néanmoins
confirmé d'urban comme 46e président
mais jusqu'au 20 janvier
il n'y a qu'une seule administration
américaine une seule diplomatie
américaine et de ce point de vue la
diplomatie américaine comme les
diplomaties occidentales sont face à une
nouvelle configuration stratégique votre
reportage évoque le cessez le feu qui a
été signé au karabagh ou une effet une
dimension de la co présidence américaine
et française du groupe de minsk pour
donner l'impression que au caucase du
sud comme auparavant en syrie et en
libye et sans doute dans le golfe
persique la voix de moscou est d'une
certaine façon la cohérence d'un accord
tacite entre ankara et moscou impact
beaucoup plus que ne le faisait jusqu'à
présent les diplomaties occidentales la
l'oriental isation de ses relations
internationales la désoccidentalisation
des processus de médiation montre que
quoi qu'il arrive cette administration
et la prochaine demi trust américaines
auront besoin de travailler main dans la
main avec les états européens
et c'est peut-être ça dont il s'agira
puisque le président joe biden président
élu déclaré hu
selon lui donc à l'issue de ce vote a
déjà dit qu'il reviendrait sur la
décision américaine de sortir de
l'accord de parier sur le climat en mai
2018 et qu'il reviendrait évidemment sur
la décision américaine de sortir de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien que le
président daniel tremblay fait qu ils
médias tous quasiment immédiatement t il
comment est ce que vous voyez là futures
relations entre les etats-unis et la
france et l'europe
les européens ont appelé joe biden le
président élu à rebâtir avec arrow bâtir
un partenariat solide
emmanuel macron lui affirmé
au président élu joe biden sa volonté de
travailler avec lui en matière de lutte
antiterroriste à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre pour le prochain mandat du
président américain sans doute plus de
convergence dans le domaine de la
multilatéralité ou d'une présence
américaine beaucoup plus forte dans ce
geste sur ces sujets là d'ailleurs le
président américain a annoncé un retrait
accéléré en tout cas annoncé comme tel
durant sa campagne des troupes
américaines en irak et en afghanistan
c'est là un très mauvais signal pour la
continuité de la lutte antiterroriste
même si les progrès tout à fait
conséquents sont à a révélé dans la
lutte contre des shs la lutte
antiterroriste au sahel aussi méritent
un approfondissement et un
éclaircissement alors que les états unis
semblait donner l'impression depuis
quelques mois que la présence ou leur
présence militaire était peut-être moins
avéré qu'il n'ya quelques années ce sont
là des sujets sur lequel les européens
et les américains devront discuter
d'ailleurs et ils ont déjà commencé à le
faire l'administration de future
administration byden a déjà commencé à
discuter avec les représentants
diplomatiques européens que ce soit
français allemands et britanniques sur
ce domaine là en particulier car il
s'agit qu'il n'y ait absolument aucune
rupture dans la continuité de la lutte
antiterroriste symboliquement mike
pompéo fera un hommage national afin
participera un hommage de commémoration
des attaques de 2015 ont rappelé leur
évidemment que la situation est
particulièrement d'actualité alors même
que l'on continue à se battre au sahel
où là précisément les américains et les
français ont fait de rester on lui
obtenu des résultats tout à fait
conséquente durant ces derniers jours
avec la mise hors d'état de nuire du
numéro 2 deux groupes de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans
merci beaucoup m annuels dupuy président
de l'institut de prospective et
sécuritaire en europe